tous les deux vous êtes entré dans un
réseau alors que vous étiez très très
jeune on voit vous êtes très jeune
nordine décalage 18 ans un jeune les
faire 18 ans vous êtes déjà repenti
ouais ça plane sur youtube heures
youtuber mais c'est incroyable à quel
âge vous avez fait a déjà deux ans mais
comment ça se passe ben tu vas au
quartier bref demande à travailler et il
te trouves ton post et du travail
commence à tutu vos quartiers tu vas
voir qui j'ai eu ben au quartier bali
ouverture aura toujours des gens il est
présent tu vas y tu demandes à
travailler et te disent de faire quoi ça
dépend quel poste tu veux prendre c'est
quoi alors qu'est ce qu'on propose c'est
un poste d'informaticien
ce soit huguette d'accord lors suisse
avertit avenue des policiers d'accord ou
sinon tu peux vendre aussi bine vend de
la drogue et toi tu faisais quoi moi
j'ai guetté c'est tout d'accord voilà
pourquoi tu t'es repenti ben c'est j'ai
eu de la chance en fait jouer à un jeu
vidéo un jour j'ai lancé une partie au
hasard et je suis tombée sur malmö connu
j'ai parlé un peu avec lui il a mis la
vidéo sur youtube c'est un film belge et
jean bessière non
je connais en vidéo non non on en rigole
nordine mais c'est vrai que quand on le
voit aussi jeunes comme ça tu dis qu'en
plus tu ton est sorti parce que tu as eu
de la chance tu comptais continues tu
dis donc tu gagnes et combien
je peux pas vous dire combien je gagnais
mais je gagnais assez pour m'acheter à
manger m'acheter quelques sap ouais
voilà quoi tu gagnes tu as dit non ça va
rien en fait et gagné le soir et je
dépensais tous le même jour d'accord
mais comment comment tu avais tu avais
pas envie d'autre chose nathalie baye
j'allais à l'école et en même temps je
faisais ça donc c'est comme l'argent de
poche pour moi tu avais d'autres potes
qui faisaient ça ouais tu avais peur ou
tu te disais de façon je suis mineur je
m'en fous mais voilà c'est fait que chi
minh a pas de risque donc c'est ça donc
en fait tu te disais je m'en fous pire
des cas
traduit tout ouais ouais comme maintes
fois deux fois que le foyer et ont lâché
au bout de combien temps 96 heures et
c'est l'autre fois 24 heures et été tes
parents ils disent quoi bah oui s'ils
savaient pas savaient pas ils ont ils le
savent ce soir non et le saint virage
était d'accord avant tu le ty télé voix
ouais tu leur as dit alors mes parents
ouais j'aurais dit que je faisais ça et
après n'hésitez pas trop content mais vu
que j'ai arrêté ça va mais quand tu dis
ça tu te rends compte que ya plein de
jeunes qui nous regarde toi tu t'es plus
heureux maintenant oui bien sûr cette
équipe est heureux avant
de chanter bien dans cette vie n'ont pas
forcément mais tant que j'avais les sous
les soirées ça me force à me bats